[Applause]
oh you got to be
kidding me
come on
[Music]
a family dissed by a restaurant jerk
while chicago teachers won't go back to
work this week an msnbc host aren't they
all claimed he wasn't allowed into a new
york city eatery because his
four-year-old daughter wasn't vaccinated
eamonn moheeden says he tried to explain
that kids under five can't even get vast
but the restaurant told him he could sit
outside or leave or go to florida with
aoc
stare at her boyfriend's feet oh they're
delicious
so like all brave journalists he tweeted
his complaints posted a picture and
tagged the restaurant also it was a
french restaurant shocking a
five-year-old's the one person they
won't surrender to
unfair so now you're seeing what happens
when the left starts experiencing a
taste of their own coveted absolutism
and it proves the gutfeld rule nothing
bad ever ever happens until it happens
to the media or their kids now they give
here's more proof chicago public school
classes were canceled today after the
teachers union voted to switch to remote
learning weird as they claimed the
vaccines work they still won't they use
the same excuses claiming that students
and teachers are vulnerable you know i'd
respect them if they were honest and
just said children suck and leaving home
when it's cold outside is a pain in the
ass
but now even leftists are freaking out
over the union's plan and why because
again now their stupid policies are
affecting them and their little brats
but thank god for argentina the country
not my masseuse
though she is special a woman stripped
down to her underwear to use her dress
as a face mask but when she was refused
service she ran out of the store
finally someone is worse at buying ice
cream than president biden
but we sympathize people are so sick of
mass they're getting creative all over
all right everyone just coming around
doing a quick mask check hey stacy linda
great job thank you so much
kyle post-its
close enough
bill
you know what points for creativity
never change man never change
jimbo
what's uh with all this
are those mine
well i'm gonna need them back
oh yes
that was disgusting all right jason
here's the one thing i'm not gonna blame
the restaurant at this because they
because imagine you're dealing with the
media what if they didn't check the
anchor and maybe if the anchor was
testing him you know what i mean you
can't trust anybody and also the
authorities have made it your
responsibility
to do this or you could get fined right
yeah right i think the restaurant owner
should be able to do whatever they want
i mean it's a private business and if
they don't want your kid in there for
whatever reason i mean obviously you
know this is health and if they're
scared and by the way
you scared them to begin with yeah so
you know don't blame them yeah right
so
it is what it is and just take go
somewhere else and just tip big like you
know who cares okay but you know you are
right the hysteria was created by the
media cat and now he's mad that the
hysteria has bit him in the backside to
use clean language
i appreciate that what do you think
about the teachers
the teachers i mean it's obvious that
they just don't want to go back to work
because obviously like i mean it's just
obviously they don't want to go back to
work the amount of time that they've
already had at home you can't spend that
much time at home no they're they want
to go do other stuff but they want to
make it's the perfect excuse they all
band together and say oh we're scared of
covid so we can't go back in and you
don't respect us and everyone loves
teachers right yeah everyone used to yes
like like people now are starting to
turn against teachers remember it was
like so cute they had a little supplies
they worked so hard for the kids and
they got little markers and like they
don't get paid enough and they get their
little markers but now everyone like
they actually managed to make themselves
hated as teachers this is such an
amazing point that no one because my mom
was a teacher
everybody's mother was a teacher at some
point and now they're evil yeah these
are the teachers unions making this
decision to be fair although i know that
teachers are voting on it teachers
unions are evil commies that is true
they are bad we all know i don't believe
that but go ahead but here that's fine
but but here you would actually i would
like to see if we could what the results
would be remember when they used to do
these studies or these uh these hidden
camera things of guys who were retired
from the mta or whatever because they
had severe back pain right and then they
do these videos of them where they're
like powerlifting parasailing
they're on like double disability and
they find these guys it was a big you
know huge expenses over time i would
love to see these teachers if we could
just you know have some hidden camera
footage of some of them i guarantee you
the terrified of covid teachers in
chicago are out at bars nightclubs
restaurants all of it as soon as these
holidays which is what they are kick in
because they're all completely full of
crap but the democrats won't call this
out fauci won't call this out the little
coward was he they wouldn't even covet
doesn't even keep them from making out
with the students
i miss those that's the story that i
really miss derefur the pandemic has
robbed us of the teacher's student
liaisons that's a good goal uh jimmy you
get those stories all the time
this could be the straw that breaks the
back though i mean like how many parent
no parent is gonna ever support a
teacher's union and maybe we start
pulling the money out well that's what i
think there's such a demand now for
private schooling and you're hearing a
lot of you know
uh representatives say things like hey
if they're not gonna go to public school
we should get to reallocate the funding
because to cat's point they did blow the
greatest record in the world they were
getting paid to be off all summer they
were the only one who had that racket
like how much more drinking should we
pay for you to do you know what i'm
saying yeah um but in terms of the msnbc
host i do have a lot of empathy mainly
because he has to work with joy reid but
i mean when you think about what
happened at that restaurant i think it's
like the funniest thing in the world
because where was he a fancy french
restaurant right you go there to get
mistreated
it's a dominatrix that gives you
croissants at the end of the hangout so
i was actually glad it happened good you
know and as far as the woman wearing the
dress as a mask the only reason it
doesn't work is it wasn't an n95 dress
hey there it is i mean the people that
take off like the the undies or the
panties whatever and put them it is as
effective as the cloth mask the people
good point yes yes so when they get
upset and they say no sir you can't be
on the plane with i think there's a guy
i did on the plane that's not science
the science says the thong works just as
well as the mask which is not at all and
you know what i i'll add to that that
the mask isn't a bad thong
hey girl you know if you want to try
something a little fun and flirty
at the beach or at the planet fitness
steam room he's flattening the wrong
curve again 30 a.m
turnpike
exit 7. you can see it i'll be there
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else